[музыка]
друзья Добро пожаловать после того как я
снял короткий ролик на свой iPhone
небольшой буквально ролик про мой
гардероб этот ролик разлетелся по
Вотсапу по мессенджерам по социальным
сетям и ко мне начал поступать очень
много запросов по поводу того как у меня
организован
гардероб Я хотел бы сегодня более
подробно рассказать сделать такой
небольшой обзор моего гардероба И кстати
почему это вам интересно и почему я
решил поделиться с этим с вами не для
того чтобы похвастаться а для того чтобы
показать как я применяю Кайден в своей
жизни
[музыка]
смотрите мы находимся в моем охотничьем
гардеробе он называется охотничьим
потому что я с детства люблю заниматься
охотой Но на самом деле в последние годы
10 лет я больше путешествую именно в
степях на природе и поэтому название
охотничьего гардероба такое и звучит
можно его конечно назвать экспедиционный
гардероб это не имеет значения главное
как он устроен Дело в том что раньше я
ездил на охоту в экспедицию и каждый раз
покупал разные вещи и они все были
разнобойные какие-то теплые какие-то не
теплые какие-то удобные какие-то
неудобные я решил стандартизировать этот
процесс и выбрал одну фирму эта фирма
называется ситка это американская фирма
и на основе неё я создал свой охотничий
гардероб вот смотрите как это все
устроено здесь термобелью здесь низ
термобеля здесь вверх здесь брюки там
полностью шапка ту часть гардероба
отдельный потом вкратце расскажу
[музыка]
так вот у каждой моей одежде для вы
думаете что это все навалом куплено
поставлено и так далее на самом деле
есть смысл переходим на эту сторону
Дело в том что когда я собираюсь ехать
куда-либо на охоту либо в экспедицию
Сначала я смотрю Какая там температура А
еще бывает Знаете что Очень важно бывает
Я нахожусь на работе а моему водителю
надо выезжать за два дня вперед потому
что колонна же едет явно потом на
самолете прилетаю так вот я водителю
говорю собери вещи и он может Собрать
вещи без меня вот в этом еще
преимущество вот этой организации он
просто подходит и смотрит Какая
температура вот плюс 10 до нуля вот плюс
5 до -10 от -5 до -20 вот если Вы
посмотрите Вот например стандарт одежды
межсезонье называется от плюс 5 до -10
здесь сразу говорится шапка Дакота
например куртка
и здесь все написано теперь Исходя из
этого на каждом элементе одежды Вы
можете посмотреть Каждый элемент одежды
здесь у каждого одежды вот такой вот вот
я как раз открыл куртку средний вверх
хаджин жакет маргуланс средний Это
говорит о чем О том что это средний слой
вверх это говорит говорит о том что это
не брюки а верхняя часть
название модели куртки и маргуланс Это
для того чтобы если бывает на охоте у
кого-то такая же куртка чтобы мы не
потеряли или чтобы мою куртку не ввели
или Я в чужую куртку не отдела и так
далее Она можно распознать и Каждый
элемент одежды вплоть до Мы можем взять
любой термобельё
Вот посмотрите пожалуйста
в любом на любом термобелье вот берем
любой термобелью вот оно
все подписано также и брюки
термобеля вот подписаны
Каждый элемент одежды подписан и у
каждого
элемента есть свое название так вот
когда я собираюсь на охоту например что
происходит Я беру сумку
открываю сумку
и начал собираться я беру например
куртку borel Это для холодных периода
снимаю с плечиков вешу на место условно
куртку складываю сюда куртку сложил сюда
Что происходит с карточками это карточка
называется Канбан карточки Я открываю
защелку их здесь две Они зеркально
похожи друг на друга Вот эту карточку
беру
одну вот эту которая без здесь защелки а
я беру вот эту и ложу в кармашек
ложу в кармашек А вот эту карточку
Я вешаю сюда
на охоте в экспедиции
и что происходит таким образом например
мой водитель собрал мой мою сумку Я
прохожу с работы Мне нужно узнать все ли
он вещи взял я просто здесь беру и
смотрю
Все ли он вещи взял и сравниваю со
стандартом теперь Что происходит на
охоте на охоте Я охотился у меня вещи
валяются где попало Я сначала опустошаю
сумку
опустошая сумку беру
пачку кабан карточек
и складываю так верхний верх бурель
джакет должен быть беру верхний верх
сложил
и положил карточку кармашек
таким образом сумка приезжает домой
когда сумка приехала домой прихожу
достаю эту карточку
пристегиваю сюда то есть их опять
воссоединяю после этого в зависимости от
того В какой сезон я носил вот смотрите
у меня есть весна лето осень-зима
Например я носил весной я беру такой
кругляшок вешаю сюда
вы Спросите что это такое это на самом
деле я это называю Big Data
Big Data согласно которому одним
взглядом каждый год я вижу какую какой
элемент одежды в какой сезон сколько
дней я носил заметьте большой кругляшок
это значит я носил больше семи дней
маленькие кругляшки меньше семи дней
таким образом я вижу В какой сезон вот я
вот смотрите осенью носил весной носил
причем трижды весной носил больше семи
дней
вот эти 5 дней Вот это тоже больше пяти
дней летом Вот это меньше я сразу вижу
какую куртку В какой сезон сколько дней
я носил Теперь смотрите
если если не надо отдать На стирку эту
вещь я беру вещи у меня специально это
для стирки корзинки бросает туда и вешаю
вот сюда карточку стирки
Вот видите у меня с прошлой охотой
сколько висит в цирке после того как мне
постирали если надо отремонтировать
что-то подшить и так далее я переношу
сюда в ремонте
после того как мне постирали принесли
мне обычно на стол складывают я беру эту
вещь и потом вот сумки вешаю сюда и
потом прицепляю карточку
а теперь что здесь происходит смотрите
если вещь полностью порвалась либо
Потерялась я беру карточку Потому что
эти же карточки висят здесь я беру
карточку и вешу купить
купить это значит я должен эти вещи
купить после того как я зашел в Интернет
в амазоне я покупаю в амазоне купил я
это переношу куплено в пути это значит
мои мой управляющий дома Он знает что
вот эти вещи скоро должна прийти посылка
и там обязательно в этом UPS в компании
спрашивают что внутри посылки он четко
знает что внутри посылки после того как
куплена в пути я переношу в ремонте
потому что
я беру каждому элементу одежды
прикалываю свою этикетку
этикетки Все я уже заранее приготовил
можете посмотреть здесь сколько мне
различных видов этикеток
и вот это на ремонте после того как с
ремонтом мне привезли я Эту одежду беру
с этим вешаю туда и вот таким образом
Эта карточка с одеждой висит на том
месте Это было у меня где это у меня
было здесь
теперь это вот как устроено
стандарта одежды и Для чего существует
Канбан карточки и Для чего существует
вот эти кругляшки
таким образом я организовал охотничий
гардероб почему потому что это очень
важно Это та Одежда которая я не хотел
бы менять и она для меня уже комфортная
она ноская она подобна по сезону она
сделана по стандарту И на любой охоте я
выгляжу во-первых одинаково одинаково
хорошо во-вторых У меня хороший камуфляж
в третьих это Одежда очень мне комфортно
И самое главное она прямо по температуре
и я знаю что не бывает такой ситуации
когда я собрался на охоту У меня нету
какого-то элемента одежды у меня все с
собой вот таким образом вы можете
посмотреть Как организован у меня вот
носки перчатки и так далее вот
Вот вы можете посмотреть как
организованы бинокли В чем фишка я когда
беру какой-то бинокль на охоту уложу
закрываю
одним взглядом можно увидеть какой
бинокль отсутствует дальше
проблема любого дома еще это батарейки
у меня специальная коробочка надо уже
заполнять где я храню различные
батарейки здесь для всех видов батарейку
И самое главное в каждом доме куча
батареек валяется и вы не знаете они
новые не новые рабочие Нет у меня здесь
сразу такой прибор я его ставлю раз
проверяю И вот он показывает год
вот наш знаю батарейка нормальная раз
прибор на место поставил
закрыл все
вот таким образом организован мой
гардероб вот эта часть это больше
Экспедиционная
Почему здесь нету Канбан карточек и
почему это не подписано потому что это
экспирационная Одежда я ее очень часто
меняю она не имеет для меня
принципиального значения здесь видите
нету камуфляжной окраски нету
специальных требований к одежде и так
далее их просто что нашел то нашел что
износилась просто выкидываю и таким
образом управляя этим гардероб Здесь
тоже вот первым белье вот здесь у меня
все карты Казахстана Я когда мне нужно я
беру любые карты
можете посмотреть
все карты с описанием с индексами таким
образом я могу планировать любую
экспедицию
она они очень-очень подробные
вот здесь общая обзорная карта
Казахстана Ну а здесь у меня находится
обувь еще
интересен вот этот уголок
интересен вот этот уголок смотрите здесь
у меня для хайкинга
видите сразу же здесь щепы
сразу здесь шипы для если летом или по
льду ходить и так далее на ботинки
одевать и сразу же такие держалки
для палочек здесь уже фонарики тут же
тормоза для наконечники для тут же очки
все сразу здесь в одном месте
[музыка]
таким образом ребята я вам показал как
целом организован мой охотничий
экспедиционный гардероб для того чтобы
вот вы четко понимали как организовывать
какие-то ценные вещи или как внедрять
казино в быту не обязательно прям все
везде делать карточки комбайн карточки
делайте только по критические важным
вещам все остальные вещи я могу показать
во второй части этого видео как я
организовал свой обычный гардероб
который я одеваю дома и на работе и там
тоже Вы можете подчеркнуть очень много
хороших полезных идей которые вы можете
применить у себя дома в гардеробе до
следующего видео
[музыка]